low pump on the rocks take one hi little
pump on the rocks
take one [ __ ] hey GQ we live right now
on the rocks I'm about to show y'all
some of my ice oh these are H like a dub
the like six to each other let the stars
this whole is like 17 this one with like
twenty five stars
hey guys they don't mean [ __ ] they look
part I thought this was weekend this one
was like ten my last ring I lost was at
eleven I was at a strip club when I got
home all that I was [ __ ] for wearing it
I got these from my sparks I'm the only
one with these [ __ ] that each like 13
or 14 o'clock put them all on one side
I'll be falling asleep sometimes a nice
plump piece The Boondocks inspired me to
get this [ __ ] so this is me
reincarnated and the blue dogfish this
business flooded with diamonds I got
baguettes in the eyes and the teeth
yellow gold rose gold yellow gold good
mind to be pinky yellows beside it and
the rest is what got my neck set up a
step Cuban link icebox
the first custom piece I ever got done
was from Elliott just get add this is
get it it's my catchphrase it's not a
dictionary tool you can look it up
oh wait the wings are here hey bring
them wings over here man they got blue
cheese
[Laughter]
[Music]
listen guys had to get some wings I got
hungry so a boy Elliott is here to talk
to you I quit the job is wrong with
Elliott oh that oh yeah I Coachella he's
seen my Leonce a piece which is
basically how we got this idea for this
get it he dropped the song around that
time we made a misguided piece to tone
rose gold white gold opss
likes quality we want stop calling for
everything all right I make this one but
this is a Gucci like actual Gucci chain
it's a nice concept behind it and it
suits him you know this whole Gucci game
I got this chain to go with his hair but
I bought this training staff so I [ __ ]
it so this one I just had just average I
just wear that [ __ ] come on Scott
just got this one like on my birthday
this was fire
it's a two-tone Royal Oak mall tomorrow
it actually discontinued did you get
this one
no I look whines barking every song I
put out comes with a chain just get it
everything he ordered this a few months
ago when we had a single coming out
named drug addict I showed him the
Rolling Stone tongue and I was like
maybe we just do this tongue with some
pills on it I mean I try to keep it as
real colors of the actual drugs so you
got the double Cup with the purple being
coming out aji lady over here Superman
pill perks stamps got shrooms little
dolphin the tab over here for the acids
onyx Watson Tesla then you got a little
bit lean coming back so that everything
in the Bible and we created a custom
link changes to Miami Gucci link it has
both Miami Cubans and the Gucci link so
this is the first one I made got to
safety lot so I'll never pop on him so
you click the first lock in see if this
move and
that's the safety lot a lot of people
have locks that look like this but they
don't really work this engineering was
not right this one was like 380 I mean I
had to finish this from the vmas he
literally got it five minutes before you
went into the VMAs he thought it wasn't
gonna be ready he was wearing everything
else could it barely see anything I put
that [ __ ] on about to see ya just one
of the craziest change for 2018
I used vs diamonds for my pieces when
you see a lot of artists jewelry you can
notice which one is mine you know I've
got a look so it looks really good you
know they won't tell you that's where
the phrase shouldn't tell you came from
[ __ ] I went to earlier [ __ ] tell your
grandma to your kids everybody next he's
gonna be like the wind stops on that
little wing stop I stopped wing stop
with a big a swing in the middle they
gotta give you a check first